[Musique]
je sais que le changement peut faire
peur mais il peut aussi nous remplir de
joie
si j'ai appris une chose en rencontrant
une princesse sur un panneau
publicitaire c'est qu'il faut
quelquefois savoir sauter dans le vide
[Musique]
il sera comme chez toi dans cette maison
ma chérie
elle fait partie de l'aventure j'appelle
pas ça une aventure j'appelle ça un
terrain minée de promesses
félicitations la maison a juste besoin
d'un peu de travaux oui vos cerve on
creuser les doutes ajoutez une tourelle
et un balcon de vous pourrez tous sauter
ça va être bien oui
Malvina Monroe je voudrais bien vendu
cette maison mais je ne gère que les
demeures plus prestigieuses
le plus difficile c'est de réussir à
trouver le grand amour mais dans ce
monde tout est compliqué
ce monde n'est pas à ton goût tu n'as
qu'à le changer
je souhaite non d'une cacahuète comment
ça se fait que je parle
je fais le souhait de vivre un conte de
fées et tout a marché de travers ou
plutôt à merveille
[Musique]
au dernier coup de minuit plus rien ne
sera comme autrefois
[Musique]
oh Gisèle qu'avez-vous donc fait
elle est méchante méchante à souhait
[Musique]
es
vous allez voir la Bretagne ça fait
toujours un effet waouh
bienvenue à kerzelec attention à la tête
vous dormez dans la chambre de Mamie
soisique elle est née ici elle est même
morte terrible
[Musique]
vous inquiétez pas c'est la Bretagne il
y a toujours plein de trucs à faire la
palourde se situe à la limite du sable
sec mais il est mouillé ton sable
tu fais quoi maintenant je me suis
inscrite à un cours de sculpture
je travaille toujours pas quoi
tu fais piquer par le guêpe une guêpe en
Bretagne vise ma couille Valentina elle
a un cousin qui s'est fait piquer au
parti comme toi il a gonflé gonflé
gonflé et il est mort c'est Jean-Michel
avec cette météo de merde on va passer
notre temps à picoler comme pendant le
confinement soleil on devrait venir plus
souvent parce que de Lyon c'est à peine
7h porte à porte c'est gentil on a mis
plus de 8h ah bah ça c'est parce que tu
as pas suivi mon itinéraire que je vous
ai envoyé j'ai rien su moi je l'ai
envoyé sur l'autre groupe
et là vous avez mis de l'engrais
[Musique]
vous savez quoi apéro
c'est une chose horrible qui était
arrivé mais tu dois recommencer à vivre
ta vie
dans mes bras ça fera bientôt un an j'ai
planifié un projet et je cherche une
complice de crimes la tour de télévision
B67 j'ai pas fait d'escalade depuis je
comprends mais si tu refuses de
confronter tes peurs toute ta vie te
rappeur
d'accord on le fait
alors
[Musique]
j'étais vraiment bourré merde t'es
incroyable c'est cette béquille qu'il
nous faut pour le voyage
ça c'est cinglé
[Musique]
à la fois et tu me dis si tu veux faire
une halte
[Musique]
tu vois c'est facile
tu te débrouilles bien
c'est qui tu dois monter ici
et confiance en moi
alors
ça qui est en bas je le vois on a une
corde de 15 m
je peux descendre un peu plus bas encore
je crois que je peux me balancer jusque
là Hunter non
à chaque heure qui passe on s'affaiblit
ça fait maintenant 24 heures
parce que dame disait toujours si tu as
peur de mourir n'est pas peur de vivre
tout autour de nous et la vie
mais tu ne dois pas craindre la mort
un Horla
affronte la
la meilleure manière de te protéger et
de t'apprendre à te défendre par
toi-même
naître beaucoup je veux apporter la paix
l'ordre dans la galaxie
mettre
c'est la seule façon d'obtenir une
victoire totale mon cher padawan
encore
rendez-vous
[Musique]
et fatigué de me battre
je les avais prévenu que les ténèbres
rapprochés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cet automne vous ne pourrez pas échapper
aux frissons
by night cette nuit c'est chacun ou
chacune pour sa peau bonne chance à tous
et comme le dit l'expression rien ne
sert de pourrir
mais parmi vous un monstre
se fait passer pour l'un des nôtres
j'ai hâte de découvrir à quelle race de
démons tu appartiens
[Musique]
tu vas tout voir mon amour
faites pas ça
lors de ta mort se rapproche un grand
pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est avec le temps
et de durs enseignements que j'ai appris
ce que je sais de la quête de la
rédemption
j'étais un homme recherché dans la tête
était mise à prix
mais pour l'instant j'étais libre
un fugitif sans foyer ni pays bon bête
c'est un endroit où tout le monde
prenait un nouveau départ
heureusement que j'étais là vous êtes
peut-être mon ange gardien sûrement pas
il y a trop de choses diaboliques en moi
pour ça
qu'est-ce qui vous amène ne lui dites
rien on a tous des secrets je te raconte
le mien si tu me racontes le tien
merci maintenant oui mais seulement
après trois non c'est un vrai nom
c'est le quartier de sagawada ma maison
c'est ton droit ne marche pas sans que
chacun de nous aide celui qu'on a besoin
pourquoi voulez-vous aider sa galwada
payer on doit tous essayer de compenser
nos péchés
tu fréquentes des gens intéressants pour
un homme qui veut éviter les problèmes
soit je vous demande quelque chose que
vous acceptez de faire soit je mets le
feu à cet endroit
tout le monde cherche à fuir quelque
chose à bomber
ça ne marche pas crois-moi
je suis foutu dans un sacré merdier je
repartirai pas les mains vides
tu aurais dû te tirer quand on avait
l'occasion
[Musique]
tu peux te libérer de tout mais pas de
toi même
je crois que j'ai besoin de courir vers
un but au lieu de fuir
[Musique]
[Rires]
regarde une étoile filante faut que tu
fasses un vœu
c'est quoi ça
les niveaux de monoxyde de carbone
provenant de ces astéroïdes sont sans
précédent
déployer une équipe de reconnaissance à
ça monsieur vous vous trompez soyez
parés pour une activité hostile nous
sommes confrontés à quelque chose que
nous n'avons jamais vu auparavant
sauf notre fils
armurerie est plus avancée que tout ce
qu'on a vu auparavant c'est quelque
chose qui pourrait causer notre
extinction La voix est Libre
on s'en va
chacun pour soi d'accord où aller je
dois le mettre en sécurité
cet endroit est devenu un refuge depuis
que ça a commencé
on a besoin de combattants on peut se
défendre
tu veux combattre une armée
d'extraterrestres
tout le monde à l'abri
et de me battre pour toi et ton avenir
si on peut détruire le vaisseau mère on
peut détruire toute leur armée
on a été attaqué et mon fils non c'est
pas vrai
voilà la cavalerie
on renvoie tes monstres de ils viennent
et on les fait payer pour ce qu'ils nous
ont pris
il ne s'agit plus d'une guerre mais d'un
anéantissement
infiltration
sabotage
exécution on est à fait des choses
terribles au service de la rébellion
question en or quoi que tu me dises quoi
que tu te dises à toi-même
à la fin tu mourras en combattant c'est
pourriture
est-ce que tu préférerais pas frapper un
grand coup pour un vrai résultat
nous avons choisi notre camp nous
combattons le côté obscur
les rebelles ont lancé une campagne
ciblée et organisée
et arrêter
c'est le moment de les pousser à
l'erreur et ce sera à quel prix à tout
prix
à chaque jour qu'on laisse passer
ils deviennent plus forts
pour que la rébellion reprenne par
surprise pour le bien de tous
appelons ça une guerre
ils ont peur je peux te dire qu'ils ont
vraiment peur
[Musique]
cette Léa c'est une parente
votre famille vous
[Musique]
semble à l'intérieur de Dieu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
par contre ce qui m'intéresse c'est
votre histoire tout le monde connaît mon
histoire je suis le survivant
aujourd'hui bien sûr mais personne vous
a demandé comment vous allez sur les
deux
tu n'en parle surtout pas suis-moi
la fille que j'aimais au pays elle sait
pas que je suis en vie je ferai
placarder votre histoire sur toute la
[Musique]
côte et parlez-moi un peu du nazis
de variété
choix on a toujours le choix dans la vie
un animal chien entraîné
[Musique]
traître Léa kirching ski rien du tout je
suis désolé reverifie vérifier où j'ai
regardé partout je vous dis de
revérifier
[Musique]
aucune chance nous ce que tu peux faire
c'est survé tu veux me tirer dessus il
faut que tu retires le cran de sécurité
est-ce une chose que ferait un vrai
survivant demande le toi de tuer le seul
homme qui se dresse entre toi et la
chambre à gaz
c'était ça les choix qu'on devait faire
tous les jours des choix faire alors
qu'on était affamés
on avait encore jamais vu un dossier
près
je suis désolé tes choix fait quand on
se rappelle par instant qu'un jour on a
une fête
risque d'envoyer ce que d'un chemin
refroidir ombre des mourrissent avec moi
qui saigne
une femme qu'est-ce que tu aimes le plus
dans ce monde
elle vaut la peine de se battre pour
elle
elle m'a sauvé la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a un avion qui décolle demain matin
à 6h
allô c'est notre moment d'accord on a
été choisi on n'est pas là 17h ou tu
ouvres
où est mon fric
[Musique]
ce qui se passe une femme
permet d'improviser je descends aux
amateurs
[Musique]
je souhaite sûrement quel changement de
décor l'aide parce que la ville c'est
pas bon pour la et si ce serait la
chambre du bébé la maison elle est en
vente depuis un moment pourquoi
inintéressait personne il y a eu un
incident
un double missile en laisse tomber je
suis pause non j'ai toujours aimé les
maisons hantées on l'achète
c'est presque trop beau pour être vrai
[Musique]
ils étaient deux je suis vraiment désolé
j'ai pas voulu vous effrayer je présume
que vous êtes pas des gens d'ici
qui êtes-vous disons que je suis ce que
vous avez de plus proche d'un voisin
qu'est-ce qui est arrivé au petit camion
je sais pas pourquoi des choses
disparaissent vous avez cessé la
thérapie suite au déménagement
[Musique]
j'ai remarqué que les fenêtres de la
chambre étaient cloués
pour pas que les gens se rendent compte
de ce qui lui faisait
qu'est-ce que ça va lui ressemble
et parlez-moi du garçon qui n'a pas été
tué et il habite la maison juste à côté
c'est cette maison
pas l'impression d'être seul ici
[Applaudissements]
l'armoire de bois il y a une raison pour
laquelle on l'a mis là
[Musique]
coucou les chasseurs on a décidé de vous
faire visiter l'un des endroits les plus
hantés du monde l'histoire de ces lieux
est absolument incroyable et je peux
vous assurer que vous sentez leur
présence autour de vous allez pense même
pas
combien de temps qu'il est là dedans
[Musique]
ça doit être maman
je dois retourner chez nous je veux
savoir ce qui s'est passé
mais il faut que j'aille au parc
[Musique]
la nuit des lumières c'est le nom que
les gens du village ont donné à la nuit
ou tes parents ont disparu
[Musique]
je suis sûr de ce que j'ai vu je t'avais
dit que ton père était dans la maison la
malédiction
c'est pas possible
c'était pas ta mère c'est le
[Musique]
parc très clair ici on a affaire à une
force de l'au-delà ce sont les lumières
du parc qui provoque les cauchemars
[Applaudissements]
non ça recommence
[Musique]
la fin de toute chose est le début d'une
autre
je suis vraiment contente que tu sois là
je veux que tu passes un bon weekend
[Musique]
avec une fille
tu vas devoir me rendre à tout ça j'ai
pas encore pris mon café excuse-moi
[Musique]
il suffit que tu regardes ta mère
épouse-moi d'accord
et tu sauras ce que je veux dire par
beauté
il a écrit ce journal rien que pour toi
d'après une histoire vraie
[Musique]
l'amour est un choix Jordan et le
véritable amour
requiert le sens du sacrifice
mais la douleur est momentanée
le véritable amour dure toujours
mais souviens-toi Jordan
tu dois te battre pour le garder
[Musique]